-You have a wonderful
special on Netflix.
Not one of your
stand-up specials
but "A Sack-Lunch Bunch."
-Oh, yeah.
-It was a -- I was lucky enoug
to meet the bunch.
We did, at 92nd Street Y.
-You met the Bunch.
-And have you re-connected
Have you been in contact wit
the Bunch during this time
-Yeah, I've done a couple
Zoom reunions with the Bunch
And this is a group of 15
8- to 13-year-olds.
-[ Laughs ]
-And they're my close friends.
So we -- [ Laughs ]
We did a Zoom reunion,
and, uh, they --
I lost their attention quickly
-Gotcha.
-They were all -- I think they
were playing "Animal Crossing.
And they all started
talking about that.
And they were excited
when I came into the Zoom room
but then I just became
another box in the corner,
struggling, struggling
to get their attention.
They've been creative over -
during this time.
They're out of school.
Some of them are like,
"We're on Broadway, anyway,"
so they're already
out of school.
But now they're home, and, uh...
they have been drawing me
in a variety of ways.
-Yeah. What is a VSCO drawing,
if we show it real quick?
-A VSCO girl...
-Okay.
-...is a type --
Do you want me to explain
what a VSCO girl is first?
-That'd be helpful, I think.
-Okay.
I don't know.
-The closest I can get is,
I think it's like what you and I
would've called, like,
a valley girl.
-Okay. Yeah.
-Okay, I'll read you
some descriptions
from "New York Magazine."
A VSCO girl is
a manic pixie eco-warrior.
You got that?
-Okay.
-Otherwise known as an annoying,
white helpless romantic.
They wear
Brandy Melville crop tops
and oversized T's
that eclipse their jean shorts
And they wear
a lot of scrunchies.
-All right.
-Okay?
And their catchphrase is
"And I oop," or "Sk-sk-sk-sk,"
which is S-K-S-K-S-K-S-K.
Which is supposed to mimic
how they laugh, I guess.
-Okay.
-And I don't --
I want to say this
in a non-creepy way --
I'm deeply interested
in the world of VSCO girls
-Does it stand for something
Is it, like --
What is the name --
-Oh, VSCO is
a social-media platform wher
you can, like, photo edit.
-I see. Gotcha.
-I don't know.
I'm repeating that
like a parrot.
So, one young lady,
Linder Sutton,
drew me as a VSCO girl.
She then deciphered
the photo for me.
Which was that --
I'm carrying a hydro flask
which is something
VSCO girls do.
And I have
a bunch of scrunchies,
'cause that's something
VSCO girls do.
And I have Carmex, 'cause
VSCO girls carry chapstick
-Gotcha. All right.
-And I have a square backpack,
'cause VSCO girls have those
Fjallraven Dutch backpack.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Right, right, right.
-That's a good pronunciation
-"Fah-jil-raven."
-What's it called?
-Fjallraven?
I think it's pronounced
"fall raven."
-So, I just said the "J."
-Yeah, that's fine.
-All right, "Fah-jil-raven."
Anyway, tomato, to-mah-to.
I'm a VSCO girl.
[ Both laugh ]
-Are you productive at all
I think that there's sometimes
this burden of feeling
like we should be doing more
with our quarantine going.
-Yeah, that's a strange burden
we place on ourselves.
I mean, I'm pretty productive.
I'm watching "Housewives."
-Yep.
-I'm --
I'm e-mailing, and I'm texting
-You're cultivating
that relationship
with those 8- to 13-year-olds.
-I've done a couple Zooms.
I don't like the way you
described it.
[ Both laugh ]
And, you know, I will --
I'll make something
that's already been made
by Trader Joe's.
I'll heat that up.
-I see.
Gotcha, gotcha.
All right.
-And I took a personality test
while in quarantine.
-Called the Myers-Briggs test,
which is like your name.
-[ Laughs ]
-Have you ever taken that test
by the way?
-I don't think I have.
What did you end up with?
What was your --
-I am an ESFP.
-ESFP.
-An ESFP.
Which is extroverted, sensing,
feeling, and perceiving.
You want to know some
characteristics of me?
-Yeah.
-I mean, if you haven't
picked these up knowing me
you're a jerk, but...
"Where's the party?"
Question mark.
"ESFPs love people, excitement
telling stories,
and having fun."
-Yeah.
-Definitely me.
"The spontaneous,
impulsive nature
of this type of personality is
almost always entertaining
And ESFPs love to entertai
on stage..."
-Whoa!
-"...or at work."
I guess same thing.
-Yeah.
-"ESFPs sometimes think and talk
in more of a spider-web
approach.
ESFPs often jump from though
to thought in mid-sentence..
[ Both laugh ]
...catching here and there
in a manner that's
almost incoherent
to the listener."
Have you found that out to b
true hanging out with me?
-I've found that the more
I hang out with you --
-Like, remember
on writing nights?
Remember, like, those Tuesdays
when we would talk and talk?
That was pretty great, right
-Yeah, yeah, that was fun --
-What were you saying?
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-And lastly, "Almost every ESF
loves to talk.
Some can be identified
by the 20-minute conversatio
required to ask or answer
a simple factual question.
-Great.
So that must be rewarding
when you take a personality test
and then you feel like
it hit some of the marks.
-It hit way too many
of the marks.
-Yeah.
-Especially the 20 minutes
to answer one question.
Like I remember someone
once asked me, "How did
John F. Kennedy die?"
and it took me 17 minutes.
-[ Laughing ]
Thank you for being here, buddy.
-Thank you, Seth.
Great to see you.
-All right. Stay healthy.
I love you, John.
-Finish "The Thorn Birds."
I love you.
Great to see you, buddy.
-All right.
Talk to you soon.